♪♪♪
THE LIFE OF A TOP MODEL
IS THE STUFF OF DREAMS.
YOUNG GIRLS EVERYWHERE
FANTASIZE ABOUT THE GLITZ,
THE GLAMOUR,
AND THE GOAL OF TRANSFORMING
FROM AWKWARD TEENS
TO RUNWAY IDOLS.
AND THEY'RE ALL WAITING
FOR THEIR BIG BREAK.
I CAN WIN,
I KNOW IT.
I'M GONNA BLOW
EVERYBODY AWAY.
AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
STAY TUNED.
FOR OUR SIXTH CYCLE OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
I GAVE 32 PROMISING GIRLS A
CHANCE TO FLY TO LOS ANGELES
AND PROVE THEY HAD TOP MODEL
POTENTIAL.
WE MADE THEM WALK.
TALK.
I KNOW I'M PRETTY,
YOU KNOW,
I HEAR IT ENOUGH THAT IT'S JUST
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS
WHY I'M NOT
A SUPERMODEL.
IF YOU'RE GONNA ASK ME TO GET
DOWN AND STRIP NAKED,
I WILL DO IT.
WELL?
BUT THE THING IS,
LIKE,
MY PARENTS KIND OF HAVE A THING
WITH THAT.
STRIP AWAY THEIR FAÇADES.
I DID SOME AMATEUR NIGHTS AT
STRIP CLUBS, LIKE, FOR MONEY.
AND SHOW ME
THEIR TRUE SELVES.
I DID NOT COME
ALL THE WAY
FROM LITTLE BITTY
LITTLE ROCK, ARKANSAS
TO GET TURNED AROUND
AND GO HOME,
THAT'S NOT
AN OPTION.
I'M A REAL
LIVE--
I KEEP CHARGING
TILL I GET WHAT I WANT
AND I WANT THIS
RIGHT HERE.
I'M NOT PLAYING!
WE MADE IT!
(screaming)
IN THE END,
I CHOSE 13 GIRLS TO MOVE
INTO THE TOP MODEL HOUSE
AND COMPETE
FOR THEIR ULTIMATE DREAM.
NOW ONLY FIVE GIRLS
REMAIN.
JADE.
FURONDA.
JOANIE.
DANIELLE.
AND SARA.
TONIGHT, SEE HOW
IT ALL WENT DOWN.
THIS IS NOT "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
BEST FRIEND."
PLUS, NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN
MODEL MOMENTS,
INCLUDING CLASSIC ADVICE
FROM OUR FAVORITE CLASSIC
SUPERMODEL.
YOU, OUT OF
ALL THE GIRLS,
YOU'VE GOT TO GROOM YOURSELF
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
AND AN UNUSUAL APPROACH TO
BONDING.
(crunching)
OW, GINA!
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
THE COMPETITION WAS
OFF AND RUNNING
WHEN THE TOP 13 MOVED INTO
THEIR LUSH L.A. MANSION.
(girls shouting)
THIS IS DEFINITELY THE CRAZIEST,
MOST BEAUTIFUL HOUSE
I'VE EVER BEEN IN.
YOU HAD
THE IMAN ROOM,
TWIGGY'S ROOM,
WE HAD
JANICE'S ROOM.
NIGEL,
I WAS LIKE,
I NEVER KNEW
HE WAS A MODEL.
THAT WAS BAD--
HE'S IN THERE!
I KNOW,
I SAW HIM,
HE LOOKED HOT.
HE'S HOT.
HE STILL
IS HOT.
OH, WE GOT
GUMBALLS!
OH.
FURONDA SETTLED INTO
THE HIGH LIFE WITH EASE.
CONFIDENCE IS THE MAJOR FACTOR
IN MODELING.
I'M THE PRINCESS AND THE QUEEN
OF THE HOUSE
AND I JUST HAVE TO LET THE GIRLS
KNOW THAT I'M SO SPECIAL.
I LIKE HOW HER TIARA,
LIKE, IS NOT COMING OFF.
THIS IS UNREAL.
FURONDA PUTS ON HER LITTLE,
LIKE, TIARA CROWN.
I'M LIKE,
WHO DOES THAT?
IT JUST SEEMS A LITTLE TACKY
AND FAKE TO ME.
WHILE SOUTHERN BELLE KATHY
WAS WIDE-EYED.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THIS.
THIS IS, LIKE, THE TEMPLE OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
MY FOLKS
DON'T REALLY GET
THE WHOLE "GOING OFF TO
HOLLYWOOD TO BECOME A MODEL"
BECAUSE THEY ALMOST WANT ME
TO KIND OF STAY AT HOME
AND BE
A HOUSEWIFE.
CHICKEN NOODLE!
IT'S MY FAVORITE!
CHICKEN
AND NOODLE.
IT'S MY FAVORITE.
BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
GET TO DO THIS?
IT'S LIKE GOING
TO THE MOON.
BUT THE VERY FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT,
WE DIDN'T WANT THE GIRLS TO BE
ABLE TO PLAY IT SAFE.
SO WE WENT
TO THE EXTREME
AND GAVE THEM ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO HIDE BEHIND.
THEY PAINTED OUR HEADS SO THAT
WE LOOKED BALD
AND IT REALLY, REALLY LOOKED
LIKE WE WERE BALD.
ARE YOU
THE DIVA?
SUPPOSEDLY.
I AM THE DIVA,
HOW'D YOU KNOW?
I THINK MY FACE
IS MY BEST ASSET.
I'M READY TO GET
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
IN THE MIRROR,
SO I KNOW
I'M GONNA ROCK IT.
SOME GIRLS DID ROCK IT
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
VERY NICE,
BEAUTIFUL.
THAT'S REALLY
ELEGANT.
THAT'S VERY NICE.
HIGH-FIVE, 'CAUSE THIS--
THIS IS FIERCE.
WHILE OTHER GIRLS,
INCLUDING THE FEARLESS FURONDA,
STRUGGLED.
WHEN FURONDA GOT IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA,
SHE WAS
NOT ONLY AWKWARD,
SHE REALLY DIDN'T
KNOW HER ANGLES.
OOH!
I DO KIND OF FEEL LIKE
A PENIS WITH EARS.
I'M WEARING A CONDOM ON MY HEAD,
A HUGE CONDOM.
LOWER YOUR HAND
A LITTLE BIT.
I NEED A LITTLE MORE WARMTH
IN THE FACE.
THINK OF SOMETHING THAT MAKES
YOU HAPPY.
HAPPY?
HAPPY,
I'M HAPPY.
MY BOYFRIEND.
FLOWERS.
WATER.
I'M HAPPY.
AT JUDGING,
THE CONFIDENT FURONDA HAD THE
RUG PULLED OUT FROM UNDER HER.
FURONDA, YOU THOUGHT
THAT YOU DID AN AMAZING JOB
IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOT.
SOME OF THE JUDGES
THINK YOU DID THE WORST.
THE GIRL WITH THE WORST PHOTO
IN THE BUNCH.
KATHY.
BUT WITH ALL OF KATHY'S
DOWN-HOME QUALITIES.
YOU HAVE
TERRIBLE POSTURE.
RELAX YOUR ARMS.
BACK.
"AHH."
AHH!
THE JUDGES JUST COULDN'T
SEE A TOP MODEL IN HER.
IT'S-- IT'S NOT
A MODEL'S FACE.
IN EVERY HOME TOWN, THERE ARE
GIRLS THAT LOOK LIKE KATHY.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
COMING UP,
JADE GETS A SPELLING LESSON.
HOW DO YOU SPELL "ET CETERA"?
E-X-C-E-D-E-R-A.
IS THAT WRONG?
AND LATER, THE GIRLS THINK THE
JUDGES MADE A BIG MISTAKE.
I'VE NEVER BEEN IN SO MUCH
SHOCK, I THINK.
♪♪♪
I WANT
A MOHAWK.
WORD?
I WANT THAT, WITH THE COLLARS
POPPED,
THEY DID SOMETHING CRAZY.
IT ALWAYS TURNS THE COMPETITION
UPSIDE-DOWN
TO GIVE THE GIRLS
BRAND-NEW LOOKS,
SO I SENT ALL OF THEM
TO THE SALON FOR A MAKEOVER.
OR JUST, LIKE, EXTENSIONS, LIKE,
THAT MATCH MY NATURAL HAIR
OR I COULD DO
THE STRAIGHT THING,
BUT I WANT, LIKE A--
LIKE A BRONZE COPPER.
BUT ON MAKEOVER DAY,
WHAT THE GIRLS WANT IS NOT
ALWAYS WHAT THE GIRLS GET.
JADE, WE WANT TO MAKE YOU LOOK
SOFTER, SWEETER, ELFLIKE.
THIS SHORT, BLONDISH,
WITH BLONDISH EYEBROWS.
I WAS REALLY SHOCKED
ABOUT THAT.
IT FREAKED ME
OUT.
♪♪♪
SOME GIRLS WERE THRILLED WITH
THEIR NEW LOOKS.
THE HAIR IS JUST REALLY
VERSATILE,
ENDED UP GIVING ME A LOT MORE
TO WORK WITH WITH MY LOOK.
SOME JUST TRIED
TO PLAY ALONG.
TRY GETTING
MORE USED TO IT.
WHY?
AND JADE STARTED
TO UNRAVEL.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY'RE LEAVING
MY TOP LONGER THAN MY SIDES.
ANTONIO,
WAS LIKE,
WE'RE GONNA CUT THIS SHORT
AND LEAVE THIS HIGH.
I FEEL LIKE LENGTH
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
IF YOU LOOK
AT ANY MAGAZINE,
A LOT OF MODELS HAVE LONG,
"LENGTHLY" HAIR.
LOOK, THIS IS
WHAT I SHOULD HAVE.
DAMN IT.
I GUESS THEY THOUGHT
I WAS JUST TOO CONFIDENT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
FURONDA'S, LIKE,
MORE ARROGANT THAN YOU.
YEAH, DUDE--
YOU THINK I'M ARROGANT?
NO, I DIDN'T SAY--
NO, NO, I SAID
MORE THAN
I WOULD THINK YOU WOULD BE
CALLED OUT FIRST.
I'M NOT ARROGANT.
NO, NO, NO,
I DON'T THINK SO EITHER.
I DIDN'T WANT TO EVEN
LOOK IN THE MIRROR
'CAUSE I WAS STILL NOT ADJUSTED
TO THE WAY I LOOK.
I DON'T EVEN LOOK
LIKE I BELONG ON THIS PLANET.
FOR DANIELLE,
THE HAIR ON HER HEAD WASN'T THE
ONLY THING THAT GOT REDONE.
MINIMAL GROOMING
AROUND THE LIP
WILL HELP A WOMAN OUT
FROM LOOKING LIKE A MAN.
YOU TRYING TO SAY
I LOOK LIKE A MAN, MR. JAY?
I DON'T THINK
YOU LOOK LIKE A MAN,
BUT YOU DON'T WANNA
BE CONFUSED FOR-- SEE?
NOT PRETTY.
DOES IT HURT,
LIKE, REALLY BAD?
NO.
YOU TELLING
THE TRUTH?
HOO.
I HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY BUTCHED
ON THE SIDES.
I'M TRYING MY BEST
TO GET USED TO IT,
BUT THIS IS THE COMPLETE
OPPOSITE OF MY PERSONAL STYLE.
I WAS SITTING THERE AND I WAS
LIKE, I AM NOT GONNA CRY,
LIKE, I WILL NOT
BE THAT GIRL.
And you're always gonna
be true to yourself.
And you're
still there.
You're still Sara.
YEAH.
I mean, your hair is just
a little different-- so what?
In college, Sara,
I shaved my head except for
two, little, like, horns.
I mean, I know your hair
don't look that bad.
ALTHOUGH SOME OF THE GIRLS
WEREN'T EXACTLY THRILLED
WITH THEIR NEW LOOK,
FURONDA WAS SO CALM AND
CONFIDENT WITH HER NEW HAIR
THAT SHE DECIDED TO LET HER
ROOMMATES KNOW
EXACTLY WHO WAS
IN CHARGE.
I'M ABOUT
TO HAND OUT MY RULES.
I'LL DO IT
IN MY FURONDA ACCENT.
"IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH ANY
OF YOUR ACTIONS TOWARD ME,
"I WILL FIND YOU AND TRY
TO RESOLVE THE PROBLEM.
"FEEL FREE
TO DO THE SAME."
(laughing)
AND YOU SPELLED "ET CETERA"
WRONG, DING-DONG.
HOW DO YOU SPELL
"ET CETERA"?
E-X-C-E-D-E-R-A.
IT TOOK ME A MINUTE,
YO?
WAIT.
E-X-C-E-D-E-A-R.
"ET CETERA."
(laughing)
IS THAT WRONG?
DID YOU, LIKE,
WRITE THIS BEFORE YOU CAME?
WHAT IS
THIS ABOUT?
TO MAKE RULES FOR EVERYBODY,
LIKE, WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
LADIES!
HELLO.
FURONDA'S TIPS HAD
ALL THE GIRLS TALKING.
"NUMBER ONE.
"I WILL RESPECT YOU AND
ALL OF YOUR BELONGINGS.
"PLEASE SHOW ME THE SAME
COURTESY."
ARE WE IN KINDERGARTEN
AGAIN?
LIKE, FOR REAL,
FOR REAL?
"NUMBER TWO,
IF YOU MUST DISCUSS ME,
"I AM THE BEST PERSON
TO DISCUSS ME WITH."
I HAD A COPY FOR YOU,
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GIVE HER YOURS.
THIS IS
COMMON KNOWLEDGE.
LIKE, THIS IS
JUST PATRONIZING.
IF YOU WANNA
THROW IT AWAY,
YOU CAN THROW IT AWAY,
BUT I GAVE IT TO YOU.
EVERY GIRL HAS TO MAKE
SACRIFICES TO COMPETE.
BUT WHEN WENDY CAME
TO "TOP MODEL",
SHE LEFT BEHIND
A LIFE IN TURMOIL.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT NEW
ORLEANS AND HURRICANE KATRINA.
I'M SLOWLY GETTING OVER
EVERYTHING FROM NEW ORLEANS.
I DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE MY PARENTS WERE.
THEY WERE TRYING
TO EVACUATE
AND THEY JUST SLEPT IN A CAR
FOR, LIKE, TWO DAYS
AND THAT WAS THE LAST TIME
I TALKED TO 'EM.
(crying)
SORRY.
I DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE MY PARENTS WERE
AND THEN FINALLY,
WE GOT IN TOUCH.
We had, like, eight-and-a-half
feet of water in the house.
You couldn't walk anywhere
because that muddy,
sludgy stuff?
That's, like,
maybe five inches thick.
AND JADE STRUGGLED
TO KEEP IT TOGETHER.
YO, I NEED
TO USE THE PHONE.
I HAVE NOT USED THE PHONE,
LIKE, SINCE I GOT MY HAIR CUT.
MAY I PLEASE USE
THE PHONE?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WELL, GIVE ME A TIME,
THEN, PLEASE.
I HAD TO GET UP
AT 3:00 IN THE MORNING.
I HADN'T TALKED TO MY FAMILY
SINCE MY MAKEOVER,
SO EVERYTHING WAS BUILDING UP
INSIDE OF ME.
YO, I'M TIRED
OF STRUGGLING.
I FEEL LIKE I AM THE
UNDISCOVERED SUPERMODEL,
YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING?
I LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY,
THE BELLY OF THE BEAST.
I'M TIRED
OF THIS.
SHE'S NOT FROM THIS PLANET,
SO SHE SAYS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK
I BELIEVE IT.
THIS IS UGLY.
AND THIS IS WHAT I SAID IN THE
CAR AND I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS,
THIS IS
GONNA GET UGLY.
A COMPETITION.
THIS IS NOT "AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP BEST FRIEND."
MAYBE SHE'S BIPOLAR
OR SOMETHING,
BECAUSE THE BEHAVIOR
THAT SHE DISPLAYED
WAS JUST
TOTALLY ERRATIC.
I AM BLONDE,
I AM SHORT.
I'M UNBALANCED.
YOU
UNDERSTAND?
AND YOU'RE WEARING A CROWN ON
YOUR HEAD, YOU LOOK RIDICULOUS.
THEY AIN'T EVEN
REAL DIAMONDS.
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
BABY.
RECOGNIZE,
AND DON'T FORGET.
AND YOU WEAR THAT CROWN,
MISS DIVA, YOU WEAR IT,
'CAUSE BELIEVE ME, YOU WILL SEE
WHO IS THE DIVA.
THE HOT TEMPERS IN THE HOUSE
COOLED DOWN
AT THE NEXT DAY'S
PHOTO SHOOT.
TODAY'S SHOOT IS ON THIS AMAZING
SET MADE OF ICE.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
HOLD ON.
OH, THAT IS SO MEAN.
I LIVED IN AFRICA
FOR 12 YEARS,
IT DOESN'T GO
BELOW 80 DEGREES.
AND I LIVE IN TEXAS NOW,
AND I'VE NEVER SEEN SNOW, SO.
WELL, NOW YOU'RE GONNA
GET YOUR LESSON
AND YOU HAVE NO HAIR
TO KEEP YOU WARM
AND I DON'T HAVE A HAT
FOR YOU, EITHER.
SO YOUR CHALLENGE IS NOW--
YOU CAN GIVE ME--
OH, HELL NO,
I'M NOT GIVING YOU MY HAT.
THE CHALLENGE WAS CHILLING
FOR THE GIRLS.
JUST LIKE THAT.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULD BE
EXCITED TO WEAR A DIAMOND THONG,
BUT IT'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT STORY
WHEN YOU HAVE TO SIT DOWN
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME
ON A BENCH
MADE OF ICE.
MY FEAR WAS THAT MY BUTT WAS
GONNA STICK TO IT.
USUALLY,
WHEN YOU'RE TAKING PICTURES,
IF IT FEELS REALLY AWKWARD,
IT LOOKS GREAT
AND THIS WAS ONE
OF THOSE TIMES
WHERE PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING
FELT AWKWARD.
GOOD, CHIN DOWN.
LITTLE MORE.
WITH HER MIND
ON OTHER THINGS,
WENDY COULDN'T FOCUS
ON HER POSES.
OKAY, WENDY,
LET ME SHOW YOU SOMETHING.
DOES THAT
LOOK PRETTY?
I FEEL LIKE WENDY'S STATE
OF MIND READS ON HER FACE.
A LITTLE
LESS SEVERE.
GOOD, BEAUTIFUL.
STILL THROWN OFF
BY HER NEW LOOK,
JADE LET THE CHILLY ATMOSPHERE
CREEP UP INTO HER FACE.
IT'S NOT A SQUINT,
IT'S A SMILE.
THAT'S A SMILE?
MY EYES
ARE JUST DIFFERENT.
AT JUDGING, THE PANEL WAS NOT
IMPRESSED WITH JADE'S PHOTO.
NOW, WHY PROFILE?
I JUST DON'T THINK
YOU CAN DO A COVER SHOT
AND NOT LOOK
AT THE CAMERA.
I MEAN,
IT JUST DOESN'T WORK.
BUT IT WAS THE VACANCY IN
WENDY'S EYES
THAT WORRIED
THE PANEL.
THE JUDGES SEE A MODEL
IN PERSON.
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN THAT POTENTIAL
PUT INTO A PHOTO.
SO JADE SURVIVED AND
WENDY WAS ELIMINATED.
AND WENDY, YOU HAVE HAD
A LONG, LONG JOURNEY
AND YOU HAVE GONE
THROUGH HELL AND BACK,
BUT YOU'RE HERE.
AND WHAT YOU REPRESENT TO ME
IS SOMEBODY THAT'S STRONG,
SOMEBODY THAT PERSEVERES
IN THE FACE OF ADVERSITY.
SO WHEN YOU GO
TO BED AT NIGHT,
I DON'T WANT YOU
TO FEEL LIKE A LOSER,
BECAUSE
IN MY BOOK,
YOU'RE A WINNER.
AND I MEAN
THAT.
GIVE ME
A HUG.
YOU CAN
STILL MODEL.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
BUT YOU CAN
STILL MODEL.
THANK YOU...
FOR BRINGING ME
THIS FAR.
THANK YOU.
AFTER A FEW WEEKS
IN THE COMPETITION,
THE GIRLS STARTED GETTING
COMFORTABLE AND OPENING UP.
DO YOU KNOW I LOOKED EXACTLY
LIKE MISS PIGGY
WHEN I WAS LITTLE?
I WAS SO FAT.
LIKE, ABNORMALLY FAT
WHEN I CAME OUT.
IF I WORE CORDUROY,
I WOULD, LIKE, START FIRES
WITH MY THIGHS.
AND SOME OF THE GIRLS
GOT TOO COMFORTABLE.
HOW MANY SHOES DO YOU HAVE,
LIKE, TOTAL?
I DON'T EVEN--
MY DAD, HAS,
LIKE SHELVES BUILT.
I LOVE HANGING OUT
WITH DANIELLE,
SHE'S REALLY COOL,
I LIKE HER HUMOR.
(crunching)
OW, GINA!
I CAN'T HELP IT, LIKE,
THE MORE YOU JUST,
LIKE, WE'RE TALKING,
I JUST--
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS WRONG
WITH GINA,
BUT DANG, I'M SCARED,
FOR REAL.
HAVE YOU DONE THAT
ALL YOUR LIFE?
UM, LIKE,
THE PAST YEAR.
THIS GIRL RIGHT HERE,
SHE'S OFF
THE WALL.
YEAH, SHE BITES,
INSTEAD OF KISSES.
SHE BITES.
I JUST WANNA,
LIKE, BITE YOU.
I DID THAT
WITH HER,
I DID IT
WITH A FEW OTHERS.
WELL, I DON'T, LIKE, TASTE THEM,
I JUST GO, LIKE--
I'M LIKE,
"WHAT PAGE ARE YOU ON, HONEY?"
'CAUSE WE'RE ON,
LIKE, 14,
YOU'RE ON, LIKE,
40 MILLION.
WE KNOW WHAT YOU DO
WITH YOUR BOYFRIEND.
GOD, YOU GOT
A PROBLEM.
THAT'S NOT NORMAL.
SOMETIMES I'M NOT EVEN AWARE
THAT I'M DOING IT.
RIGHT THERE, STOP.
OKAY, I'M DONE.
LATER THAT DAY, I HAD A CRYPTIC
MESSAGE FOR THE GIRLS.
I DON'T THINK
I CAN PRONOUNCE THIS.
"GROMPHADORINA
PORTENTOSA."
WHAT IN THE WORLD
IS THAT?
GROMPHADORINA...
GRUMPA...
SKRILLIUMPTIOUS!
L.A. DESIGNER JARED GOLD
WAS KIND ENOUGH
TO HELP THE GIRLS FIGURE OUT
JUST WHAT MY CLUE MEANT.
THESE ARE GIANT MADAGASCAR
HISSING COCKROACHES.
(gasping)
WE HAVE ACTUALLY USED THESE
ROACHES IN RUNWAY SHOWS BEFORE.
OH, DON'T
DO THIS.
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO HAVE
TO WEAR ONE OF THESE.
(gasping)
I SEE THESE LITTLE THINGS,
LIKE, MOVING
AND I SEE THE LEGS MOVING
AND I'M LIKE, OH!
THEY'RE ABOUT
150 BUCKS EACH.
THE ROACHES?
- UH-HUH.
- WHAT?
FOR $150, YOU COULD HAVE
YOUR OWN LITTLE PET
CRAWLING ON YOU
AT ALL TIMES.
IT'S A GREAT DEAL.
I'M SO PROUD,
NO ONE'S CRYING YET.
GO!
I WOULD NOT WEAR THIS
IN MY CASKET AT MY FUNERAL,
BUT I WALKED IT,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU GOTTA DO
WHEN YOU A MODEL.
YOU CAN'T COMPLAIN.
THE ROACH I HAD ON ME
HAD EATEN HIS LEG OFF,
WHICH IS WHY HE DIDN'T
MOVE A LOT
AND I ALMOST FELT BAD
FOR THE ROACH.
OKAY, GO.
HE'S PISSED.
(laughing)
DID YOU SEE THAT?
SHE TOOK IT
IN HER HAND!
JADE'S BOLDNESS
BLEW JARED GOLD AWAY.
OH, SHE KISSED IT!
DUDE, THEY LOVED IT
AND I WAS LIKE, HELL YES.
JADE,
YOU'RE AWESOME.
BUT SOME
TRIUMPHANT TEASING--
JUST KISS IT,
COME ON.
KISS IT, KISS IT.
NO,
IT'S OKAY.
SENT GINA'S ROACH PHOBIA
INTO OVERDRIVE.
GINA WAS FREAKING OUT.
GO!
(squealing)
YOU CAN'T ENTER THIS COMPETITION
IF YOU'RE A TOTAL WRECK, MESS.
(girls)
OH!
GET IT OFF ME,
PLEASE!
WITH A LITTLE EXPERIENCE
UNDER THEIR BELT,
IT WAS TIME FOR THE GIRLS
TO WALK THE WALK
IN SUPER-HIGH
HEELS.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH, GINA,
YOU'RE CATCHING FLIES.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
OOH.
AHH!
CAREFUL.
ARE YOU OKAY?
AFTER SHE TUMBLED,
KARI'S CONFIDENCE CRUMBLED.
WHAT'S WRONG,
KARI?
I JUST WANTED TO DO WELL,
AND IT WAS A MESS
AND I KNOW
I WAS A MESS.
KARI WAS SENT HOME,
INSTEAD OF GINA
TO THE AMAZEMENT
OF THE REST OF THE GIRLS.
WHERE DOES THAT
COME FROM?
I'VE NEVER BEEN IN SO MUCH
SHOCK, I THINK.
I THINK GINA PROBABLY DESERVED
TO GO HOME
MORE SO
THAN KARI DID.
YOU GOTTA
STOP CRYING,
YOU GOTTA GET YOUR HEAD
BACK IN COMPETITION MODE.
COMING UP,
ONE MODEL FACES
THE WRATH OF JANICE.
I'VE SEEN BETTER FACES
ON IODINE BOTTLES.
AND LATER, THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE, JADE-STYLE.
THE "RELEASEMENT"
OF STRESS.
THIS IS
REAL GOOD.
IT IS
MY FAVORITE.
GO NNENNA.
I GOTTA LEARN
HOW TO DO THAT.
DESPITE BEING HERE A FEW WEEKS,
SARA HAD TROUBLE ADJUSTING.
I DO HAVE A HARD TIME BEING
MYSELF HERE.
LIKE, I'VE ONLY KNOWN YOU GUYS
FOR, LIKE, A COUPLE WEEKS.
I KNOW.
THIS ISN'T YOU?
I FEEL LIKE IT'S EASIER
TO BE ME IN A SITUATION
WHERE I FEEL LIKE
I'M SUPPORTED.
THIS IS A COMPETITION,
MAN.
IT'S NOT EVEN
ABOUT MAKING FRIENDS,
ALTHOUGH IT'S COOL
TO MAKE FRIENDS.
BUT THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT,
LIKE, IF YOU REALLY WANT IT,
YOU KNOW?
GO.
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
WOULDN'T BE COMPLETE
WITHOUT A VISIT FROM
EVERYBODY'S FAVORITE DIVA,
JANICE DICKINSON.
DO YOU GUYS HAVE
PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS
ABOUT ME BEING A BITCH ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"?
BE HONEST.
- YES.
- A LITTLE BIT.
I DON'T CARE.
I'M HERE
TO TELL THE TRUTH.
YOU KNOW WHAT I DO
SEE IN YOU, THOUGH?
I SEE THAT YOU'RE
A LITTLE BIT UNKEMPT.
UNKEMPT,
YES.
YOU, OUT OF
ALL THE GIRLS.
YOU'VE GOT TO GROOM YOURSELF
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
BROOKE NEEDS
A LOT OF WORK.
I'VE SEEN BETTER FACES
ON IODINE BOTTLES.
THE MOST STRESSFUL PART
OF THE DAY WAS DINNER.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO,
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO!
HOW'S DINNER GONNA
BE STRESSFUL?
DINNER IS SUPPOSED TO BE A PART
OF THE DAY WHEN YOU UNWIND.
JANICE WAS THROWING FOOD
ON A LITTLE BURNER.
SHE THREW HER LASHES
ON THERE
AND KIND OF RUINED MY MEAL
A LITTLE BIT.
HOW DOES IT FEEL
TO BE BALD?
IT WENT
FROM "YES" TO "NO."
I THINK
YOU'RE GORGEOUS.
TO, "OF COURSE!"
YOU'RE VERY FRESH
AND VERY COOL.
YOU NEED
TO ARTICULATE.
I HATE YOU.
I LOVE
YOU.
YOU'RE
MY FAVORITE.
GET OUT
OF HERE!
AHH!
JANICE TRIED TO BRING GINA
OUT OF HER SHELL.
GINA, COME ON OVER HERE,
GINA.
COME HERE,
BABY.
WHO'S GIVING YOU
SOME ?
TELL ME AND I'LL GO
KICK THEIR ASS.
DO I HAVE TO?
YES.
YO!
ARE YOU
REALLY SERIOUS?
SHE JUST POINTED
AT YOU.
I DON'T LIKE DRAMA,
YOU KNOW?
I'M TIRED
OF IT.
I TOLD EVERYBODY,
YOU KNOW,
I COME WITH HUMBLENESS,
YOU KNOW?
GINA.
RULE NUMBER ONE,
WE NEVER RAT OUT OUR BITCHES.
YOU TAKE THAT STUFF HOME
WITH YOU,
YOU BURY IT.
ZIP IT,
YOU'RE DEAD IN MY BOOK.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
I FEEL LIKE SHE WAS JUST KIND
OF MORE ON JADE'S SIDE.
I THINK SHE'S INTIMIDATED
BY YOU, IF ANYTHING.
I HAVEN'T
DONE ANYTHING.
I MEAN, BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SUCH A STRONG PERSONALITY
AND YOU SHOW THAT YOU ARE
CONFIDENT ABOUT YOURSELF.
I DON'T THINK
GINA FEELS THAT.
I THINK
SHE'S WEAK, YO.
AND I THINK
SHE IS.
AND JANICE SEES THAT
IN HER.
SHE'S GETTING
BETTER.
I DON'T
THINK SO.
AT THE HOUSE, JADE DECIDED IT
WAS TIME FOR A CONFRONTATION.
YOU KNOW WHAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING,
GINA, ABOUT YOU AND ME?
LIKE, THEY'RE SAYING THAT YOU'RE
VERY INTIMIDATED BY ME.
I'M INTIMIDATED BY YOUR
IGNORANCE, JADE.
'CAUSE I'M SITTING--
CAN YOU LEAVE,
PLEASE?
I'M TIRED
AND I WANT TO GO TO BED.
I'M TRYING
TO MAKE PEACE.
I AM
SO OVER YOU.
THANK YOU.
YOU DON'T DESERVE
ANY OF MY TIME.
I'M DONE
WITH YOU.
WHAT YOU DID RIGHT NOW TONIGHT
WAS PERFECT.
YOU STOOD UP
FOR YOURSELF.
YOU DID EXACTLY WHAT YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO DO, GINA.
SHE DID EVERYTHING PERFECTLY
AND WE'RE VERY PROUD OF HER.
THE NEXT MORNING,
I HAD THE GIRLS MEET ME IN THE
DRESSING ROOM OF MY TALK SHOW.
HOW ARE Y'ALL?
SO WHAT I WANT TO DO TODAY IS
I WANT TO TALK TO ALL OF YOU
ABOUT YOUR
FUTURE GOALS.
YOU HAVE
TO BE FOCUSED,
YOU HAVE TO BE OBSESSED WITH
MODELING AND CONSUMED WITH IT
AND TREAT IT
LIKE A BUSINESS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU HAVE
TO KNOW THAT IT'S NOT FOREVER.
AFTER OUR TALK,
I SENT THE GIRLS TO A PHOTO
SHOOT WHERE THEY WOULD PORTRAY
SEXED-UP VERSIONS
OF THEIR FUTURE GOALS.
BUT OF COURSE,
THERE HAD TO BE A TWIST.
CAN I HAVE MY EXTRAS?
YEAH!
BEING AROUND ALL
OF THESE GIRLS
DEFINITELY MAKES ME
MISS A MAN.
WE GOT
SO MUCH CANDY.
I'M NOT USED TO THIS ENVIRONMENT
BEING WITH, LIKE 13 OTHER GIRLS.
ALL THE TIME.
DRAMA
I'M THIS CLOSE TO, LIKE,
GOING INSANE RIGHT NOW.
WITH GINA STILL OBSESSING
OVER JADE,
HER SHOOT
WAS AN UNFOCUSED MESS.
I'M GONNA STOP
RIGHT HERE.
HELP ME HELP YOU,
'CAUSE I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT TO SAY ANYMORE.
DO YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE
BEING A FASHION MODEL?
I'M JUST TOO DISTRACTED
WITH TRYING TO MAKE MYSELF LOOK
LIKE A FASHION DESIGNER.
LET'S FORGET THAT.
JUST MODEL
THAT OUTFIT FOR ME.
THE OTHER GIRLS TURNED UP
THE TEMPERATURE ON SET.
THE FEEL OF THE PHOTO SHOOT WAS
KIND OF SEXY, YOU KNOW,
NOT LIKE SLUTTY,
BUT YOU WERE WALKING
ON THAT FINE LINE.
BUT IT WAS NNENNA WHO REALLY
GOT THINGS COOKING.
OH, THAT ONE WAS HOT,
DID YOU SEE THAT?
THIS IS
A SEXY PHOTO SHOOT,
SO I FIGURED,
WE HAVE CHEMISTRY.
LAST FRAME.
WORK,
DAMN IT.
GIRL.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, BITCH,
WHERE YOU GOING?
WE JUST GOT DONE
WITH OUR PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
I HAD A REALLY--
AND THIS ONE.
WOO, SHE WAS
SEXY TODAY.
THE ENTIRE TIME, I WAS THINKING
OF MY BOYFRIEND, TOO.
I DIDN'T TAKE--
I WAS--
I WAS PROFESSIONAL.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU GOTTA DO
IN MODELING, YOU KNOW?
SEX SELLS.
ROCK AND ROLL.
NNENNA'S CHEMISTRY WITH THE
MALE MODEL LED TO A HOT PHOTO.
MIX THOSE CHEMICALS,
GIRL.
WAS THERE A CONNECTION
WITH THE TWO OF YOU?
I THINK
WE HAD CHEMISTRY.
I LOVE IT, GIRL,
GO FOR IT.
BY CONTRAST,
GINA'S PHOTO WAS A MESS.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE COMMITTED
TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND IN ALL THESE PICTURES,
YOU DON'T LOOK COMMITTED,
YOU LOOK HALFWAY THERE,
CONFUSED.
IT SEEMED YOU'RE JUST
SHRINKING AWAY.
THE JUDGES FINALLY LOST FAITH
IN HER POTENTIAL
AND GINA
WAS SENT HOME.
80%, I'M SAD
TO BE GOING,
BUT 20%,
I'M HAPPY
BECAUSE I WON'T BE IN THIS
STRESSFUL HOME ANYMORE
AND I WON'T HAVE TO DEAL
WITH JADE ANYMORE.
COMING UP--
THAT ROOM IS GROSS.
THE MESSY HOUSE LANDS THE GIRLS
IN HOT WATER WITH MR. JAY.
WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT MODELING TODAY,
WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT HYGIENE.
AND LATER, A DANCE-OFF,
KRUMP-STYLE.
GO JOANIE!
♪♪♪
OOF.
GIRL.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WHY DOES IT STINK
UP IN THIS PIECE?
WHOSE ROOM
IS IN THE BACK?
IT'S HERS.
MINE-- ME AND DANIELLE
AND LESLIE.
I CAME BY
FOR BREAKFAST
'CAUSE I WAS LITERALLY
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
BUT THAT ROOM-- I JUST WALKED
THROUGH IT-- IS GROSS.
JAY POPS UP AND HE'S LIKE,
"THIS HOUSE STINKS."
AND I'M LIKE,
"THAT'S WHAT I KNOW."
WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT MODELING TODAY.
WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT HYGIENE.
WHAT IS THAT ?
THAT WAS
KARI'S.
WELL, SHE'S NOT HERE ANYMORE,
SO LET'S GET RID OF IT!
JAY SEEMS A LITTLE
OBSESSIVE-COMPULSIVE
AS FAR AS, YOU KNOW,
CLEANLINESS GOES.
ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA GO.
OH, YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
BREAKFAST WITH US NOW?
OH, NO, I'M GOING
THROUGH A DRIVE-THRU.
YOU DIDN'T DO
THE DISHES YET.
WE HAVE THIS BAD STENCH
IN THE KITCHEN
AND IT MAKES ME THROW UP
A LITTLE BIT IN MY MOUTH.
LOOK AT THAT.
LET'S SEE IT.
THAT IS
DISCOLORED.
EW, IT SMELLS LIKE DEAD FLESH,
LIKE ROADKILL!
I'LL GIVE YOU $100
TO EAT THIS.
GET OUT OF HERE!
$100?
$100?-- I'LL HAVE E. COLI
AND BE DEAD AT 6:00 A.M.
BUT YOU GONNA
HAVE $100.
FURONDA,
YOU WANT SOME MONEY?
GO GET
THE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THESE GIRLS
ARE FILTHY.
THEY EAT AND LEAVE PLATES OUT
WITH FOOD STILL ON 'EM.
LOOK AT THIS--
BAM!
BAM, BAM.
WHAT ELSE
CAN WE THROW AWAY?
OH, WE'RE THROWING
THAT AWAY.
YOU SO STUPID.
WHILE SOME GIRLS FOCUSED ON
CLEANING UP,
MOLLIE SUE WORRIED ABOUT HER
PLACE IN THE COMPETITION.
LIKE, EVEN LOOKING
AROUND, LIKE,
THERE'S LESS
GIRLS HERE.
AND PEOPLE JUST TURN,
YOU KNOW, LIKE,
THE PEOPLE
YOU THINK--
AND NOW YOU REALLY
START FEELING IT,
YOU START SEEING
YOUR COMPETITION.
YEAH.
RIGHT NOW,
THINGS ARE JUST, LIKE,
THE MOST STRESSFUL
THEY'VE BEEN.
I GUESS IT'S PROBABLY
GONNA GET WORSE.
IT'S KIND OF
TAKEN A TOLL.
A TOP MODEL HAS
TO THINK ON HER FEET
AS THE GIRLS SOON LEARNED
IN A COMMERCIAL FOR COVERGIRL.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS GIVE YOU GIRLS
A COUPLE OF LINES
THAT YOU HAVE TO LAND.
NOW, THE REST OF THE SPOT
IS ALL UP TO YOU
'CAUSE IT'S ABOUT
IMPROVISATION.
WE HAD 30 SECONDS TO, LIKE,
WALK UP THE STAIRS,
AROUND, BY THE POOL AND THEN
STOP AND LAND OUR LINES.
PARTIES ARE
SO UNPREDICTABLE.
BUT YOUR MAKEUP
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
THAT'S
A GOOD LINE.
WHEN I WEAR COVERGIRL ,
I KNOW I LOOK GOOD.
HEY, EVERYONE.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED.
SHEER,
LIGHTWEIGHT COVERAGE.
EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL.
COVERGIRL.
AND CUT.
PERSONALLY,
I KNOW I DID GOOD TODAY.
SEVERAL GIRLS
STRUGGLED.
SHEER.
IT'S LONG-LASTING.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED.
THERE WAS NOTHING ENGAGING
ABOUT THAT DELIVERY.
WONDERFUL,
FABULOUS.
SHE'S
A DRAG QUEEN.
THIS IS...
(beep)
LIGHTWEIGHT MAKEUP.
(bleep)
CUT!
COVER GIRLS
DON'T SAY THAT.
BUT WHEN BROOKE FUMBLED...
SHEER LIGHT COVERAGE
MAKEUP.
(sighing)
CUT!
SHE LOST
HER COMPOSURE.
I DON'T WANNA TALK
ABOUT IT.
AT JUDGING,
JADE WAS FULL OF EXCUSES.
ALL RIGHTY, JADE,
SO YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL.
AND HERE'S
YOUR BEST TAKE.
THIS IS...
OKAY.
YOU GUYS USED
MY WORST ONE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE,
THOUGH,
HOW DIFFERENT YOU WOULD
HAVE DONE ANOTHER ONE
BECAUSE YOU'D HAVE
TO BE NIGHT AND DAY.
I HAVE WORKED FOR VICTORIA'S
SECRET FOR TEN YEARS
AND I'M LIKE, "WHY THE HELL DID
THEY CHOOSE THAT SHOT?"
BUT FOR SOME REASON,
IT WORKS FOR THEM.
YOU'LL NEVER BE 100 PERCENT
HAPPY AS A MODEL.
BUT IT WAS MOLLIE SUE
WHO STOOD OUT IN THE WRONG WAY.
FOR A LATE NIGHT, I WANT
SOMETHING LIGHT AND HASSLE-FREE.
SHEER.
LONG-LASTING.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED.
IT WASN'T
A MODEL'S PERFORMANCE.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE
YOU WERE SELLING MACE.
"YOU WANNA
KEEP 'EM AWAY?"
"YOU WANT ME TO--"
YOU KNOW?
AND HER SHORTCOMINGS ON CAMERA
GOT HER SENT HOME.
I'M SO CONFUSED
RIGHT NOW.
FOR JADE TO STAY OVER ME,
IT WAS JUST CRAZY.
NIGEL, MISS J, MR. JAY,
TWIGGY, EVERYONE,
YOU JUST KICKED
YOUR WINNER OFF FIFTH, SO.
THE COMPETITION FOR "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL" CAN BE TOUGH,
BUT FOR NNENNA,
A NEEDY BOYFRIEND BACK HOME
MADE THINGS EVEN HARDER.
You can't even--
you can't give me all this truth
of your intentions.
JOHN, JOHN.
You did.
SHE'S LIKE, "JOHN, NO, DON'T
TALK MY PERSONAL BUSINESS.
"JOHN, JOHN!
"I'M NOT GONNA TALK
TO YOU IF-- JOHN!"
YOU'RE NOT LISTENING.
NO, YOU'RE NOT.
NO,
YOU'RE NOT.
WHAT IF I BROKE UP
WITH YOU RIGHT NOW?
NNENNA BEEN ON THE PHONE
FOR AN HOUR.
SHE ON THE PHONE LIKE SHE IN HER
APARTMENT OR SOMETHING.
NNENNA IS ON THE PHONE WITH HER
BOYFRIEND, LIKE, WAY TOO LONG.
I DO UNDERSTAND,
LIKE,
YOU'RE HAVING DIFFICULTIES WITH
YOUR BOYFRIEND AND EVERYTHING,
BUT THERE IS EIGHT PEOPLE
IN THE HOUSE.
SHE MONOPOLIZES
THE PHONE
AND WHEN I TRY
TO TALK TO HER
AND BE CONSIDERATE AND DECENT
TO HER, WHAT DOES SHE DO?
SHE HAS
TO LAUGH AT ME.
EVERYBODY DOES HAVE A BREAKING
POINT TO HOW MUCH THEY CAN TAKE.
I JUST GOT
TO MY BREAKING POINT.
I'M NOT REALLY
A MEAN PERSON
BUT DEFINITELY I THINK
WHEN I GET IRRITATED
OR ANGRY OR FRUSTRATED,
I BECOME WICKED.
YOU CRY A LOT,
SO YOU KNOW,
BEING EMOTIONAL RIGHT NOW
ISN'T GONNA BOTHER ME.
WHAT HAPPENED?
THERE IS EIGHT PEOPLE
IN THE HOUSE.
SHE IS NOT
THE ONLY ONE,
THIS IS NOT HER HOUSE,
THIS IS NOT HER PHONE.
SHE LAUGHS
AT ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
HAVE TACT, HAVE CONSIDERATION
OF OTHER PEOPLE.
I CAN ONLY TAKE
SO MUCH.
THE GIRLS KNOW THAT WALKING
A STRAIGHT LINE DOWN THE RUNWAY
IS NOT AS EASY
AS IT SEEMS,
BUT THEY HADN'T SEEN ANYTHING
UNTIL THEY SAW THE SWIRL.
A SWIRL!
I'M RICHARD HARRIS.
AND I'M RON HARRIS.
AND WE'RE GONNA TEACH YOU
A SWIRL.
IT'S A MOVEMENT.
THE SKIRT IS MOVING, THE GOWN IS
MOVING, THE HAIR IS MOVING,
BUT HER PERSONALITY AND AURA
IS THE SAME.
♪♪♪
RON AND RICH,
THE TWINS,
THEY TEACH US
HOW TO SWIRL
AND THEY'RE SO FUNNY
AND SO CUTE.
OKAY.
WORK THE MOVEMENT,
WORK THE BODY.
MAKE ME
FEEL IT.
SELF-CONFIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT A MODEL
IS ALL ABOUT.
I CAN SELL IT, I CAN MOVE IT,
I CAN DO IT.
SWIRL, SWIRL, SWIRL.
RON AND RICHARD
WERE ECCENTRIC.
THAT'S THE BEST WAY
TO DESCRIBE THEM.
THEY WERE
ECCENTRIC.
THEIR AURA
WAS GREAT.
♪♪♪
SARA DID NOT PERFECT
THE TECHNIQUE
BY THE END
OF THE TEACH.
SARA WASN'T THE ONLY ONE WHO
HAD TROUBLE WITH THEIR WALK.
I CAME BACK HOME
AND PRACTICED MY RUNWAY WALK.
SWIRL.
I THINK I'M LEARNING HOW TO NOT
WALK WITH MY BUTT OUT.
I DIDN'T KNOW I WALKED
WITH MY BUTT OUT.
LIKE, I DON'T FEEL LIKE
I'M STICKING MY BUTT OUT,
BUT I GUESS
IT'S OUT.
I CAN'T WALK
LIKE THAT
WITHOUT FEELING LIKE
I'M GONNA FALL, YOU KNOW?
MY WALK IS
JUST HORRIBLE.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT
I DON'T HAVE AN ASS,
LIKE, HOW CAN I BE WALKING
WITH MY BUTT OUT?
(woman on phone)
You do!
I DIDN'T
KNOW THIS.
LIKE, WHY DOESN'T ANYONE
TELL ME THIS?
THE PHOTO SHOOT
THAT WEEK
WAS ALL ABOUT UNDERSTANDING
BODY MOVEMENT,
AS THE GIRLS
WERE JOINED
BY THE PIONEERS OF A DANCE
STYLE KNOWN AS "KRUMPING".
(chanting)
♪ HEY LADIES
HEY LADIES ♪
♪ HEY LADIES ♪
KRUMPING IS, LIKE, THIS REAL
INTENSE WAY OF DANCING.
A LOT
OF BODY MOVEMENT.
THERE YOU GO!
SOME GIRLS
ROCKED IT OUT.
WOO!
AND SOME GIRLS JUST COULDN'T
LET IT ALL HANG OUT.
IS THAT HOW YOU DANCE
FOR THE MEN?
I WANT YOU TO BE
IN THE CLUB.
I NEED
TO FEEL IT MORE.
SO AT THE END
OF THE DAY,
THE GIRLS BLEW OFF SOME STEAM
WITH A KRUMP-OFF.
WE GOT TO DO
A LITTLE BATTLE
WHERE YOU WALK UP
TO THE PERSON YOU'RE BATTLING
AND YOU JUST SHOW 'EM
YOUR MOVES
AND THEN THEY HAVE
TO DO THE SAME.
WOO!
OH!
GO JOANIE!
I PUT MY HOOD OVER MY HEAD
AND I GOT ALL DOWN AND DIRTY.
WHAT.
OH, OH, OH, OH, OH!
OH!
I NOTICED
WHEN I WALKED UP TO HER,
LIKE, I CAN JUST SEE FEAR
IN HER EYES.
THAT'S KRUMP DANCING
RIGHT THERE.
HO!
BUT THE FUN QUICKLY
CAME TO A STOP
WHEN LESLIE'S POSTURE AND
PRESENCE FAILED TO HOLD UP.
LESLIE, I THOUGHT YOU WERE
TOO POSE-Y IN YOUR SHOTS.
I DIDN'T SEE YOU
DANCING AT ALL.
AND SHE WAS
SENT HOME.
SARA.
IT'S JUST
THE MAIN FEELING
I'M FEELING RIGHT NOW
IS DISAPPOINTMENT.
I THINK MY PICTURES HAVE BEEN
GOOD, BUT OVERALL,
I HAVEN'T SHOWN THE IMPROVEMENT
THEY WANT TO SEE.
THE FEELING THAT MAYBE
IT WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH,
THAT'S WHAT'S--
THAT'S WHAT'S
DISAPPOINTING.
COMING UP,
JOANIE MAKES A NEW FRIEND.
YOU KNOW WHO'S HOT,
THOUGH?
NIGEL BARKER.
AND LATER,
DANIELLE THE DENTIST
GIVES JADE A TASTE
OF HER OWN MEDICINE.
JADE DOESN'T JUST BRING A
UNIQUE LOOK AND PERSONALITY
TO THE COMPETITION,
SHE ALSO BRINGS
A UNIQUE VOCABULARY.
I ANALYZE EVERYTHING,
EVERYBODY.
I'M JUST
AN "ANALYSTIC" PERSON.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT THE--
THE "DECIPHERATION" BETWEEN
CONFIDENCE AND COCKINESS.
I'M DEALING WITH SO MUCH
"TORNNESS."
THE "ARROGANTNESS."
I'M REALLY INTERESTED
IN ACTING,
AND, I'LL PROBABLY "DWELVE" INTO
THIS, YOU KNOW, IN THE FUTURE.
YOU KNOW, I LIKE
MY "BRUNETTENESS,"
BUT THIS IS
AN AWESOME CHANGE
AND I THINK I'M GONNA
STICK WITH IT FOR A WHILE.
SOMETIMES IT'S JUST TOO MUCH
FOR ME TO "WITHHANDLE"-
ACTUALLY, NOT "WITHHANDLE,"
THAT'S NOT A WORD.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES IT'S JUST
TOO MUCH FOR THEM TO JUST TAKE.
THE "RELEASEMENT"
OF STRESS.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WOULD WANT
TO HEAR ANY "DEROGATORINESS"
AS FAR AS, YOU KNOW, BEING
THE PERSON THAT THEY ARE.
THANK YOU
FOR "CONSIDERATING" ME.
LOTS OF PEOPLE THINK MODELS
ARE BRAINLESS LIVING DOLLS,
SO I DECIDED
TO USE A PHOTO SHOOT
TO MAKE FUN
OF THAT STEREOTYPE.
JOANIE, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
A VENTRILOQUIST'S DOLL.
BROOKE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE A GLAM DOLL.
DANIELLE, YOU ARE GONNA BE
A MARIONETTE, ALL RIGHT?
HOP INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP
AND WE ARE READY TO START.
JAY SAYS I'M GONNA BE
A MARIONETTE DOLL.
WHAT IS THAT WORD
THAT HE JUST SAID?
WHAT IS
A MARIONETTE DOLL?
WHERE'D YOU GROW UP
AGAIN?
UNDER A ROCK?
A MARIONETTE DOLL IS A DOLL
THAT IS CONTROLLED BY STRINGS.
I'M JUST JOKING,
I KNEW THAT.
YOU DID NOT KNOW THAT,
DANIELLE-- NICE TRY!
IF HE WOULD HAVE
JUST TOLD ME,
"DANIELLE, YOU GONNA BE
A DOLL WITH STRINGS,"
I WOULD HAVE BEEN LIKE, "COOL,
I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT IS,"
BUT HE HAD TO GET ALL TECHNICAL
AND SAY A MARIONETTE DOLL.
WHO SAYS THAT?
SO JOANIE, THIS IS GONNA BE
YOUR PUPPET MASTER TODAY,
HIS NAME IS ALEX.
HI!
NICE TO MEET YOU.
LIKE, PRETEND YOU'RE
IN A TRAVELING CIRCUS.
SOME OF THE GIRLS
CAME ALIVE AS LIVING DOLLS.
YOU'RE LOOKING GOOD.
NICE.
LOOK AT THESE.
BUT BROOKE COULDN'T THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX.
THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE NOT SURE ABOUT.
I NEED YOU TO WORK ON BEING
COMFORTABLE IN YOUR SKIN.
BROOKE, SHE WILL CRY, 'CAUSE
THAT'S JUST IN HER NATURE.
AND IT'S NOT
THE FIRST TIME.
IT'S NOT
THE SECOND TIME.
IT'S NOT THE THIRD TIME,
IT'S NOT THE FOURTH TIME,
IT'S NOT
THE FIFTH TIME.
BROOKE,
GET IT TOGETHER, GIRL.
(wolf whistle)
MISS J., OH NO!
HE'S CRAZY.
YOU KNOW
WHO'S HOT THOUGH?
NIGEL BARKER.
(laughing)
HE IS HOT.
I THINK I WANNA
TAKE THIS HOME WITH ME.
DESPITE HER UPBEAT
ATTITUDE,
JOANIE WAS PLAGUED
BY AN INSECURITY.
SHE'S JUST
SO BEAUTIFUL.
JOANIE HAS LOTS AND LOTS OF
EXTRA TEETH STACKED ON THE TOP,
ON THE SIDE OF HER MOUTH.
HER FRONT TOOTH IS KIND OF
CROOKED OVER HER OTHER TOOTH.
I KNOW PEOPLE ARE GONNA TURN ME
DOWN BECAUSE OF IT, YOU KNOW?
BUT WHATEVER.
BUT JOANIE'S DAYS OF BEING
SELF-CONSCIOUS WERE OVER
WHEN I SENT HER
AND ALL THE GIRLS
TO GET THEIR SMILES
PERFECTED.
WE'RE GONNA REMOVE
THESE FOUR.
TODAY?
WE'RE GONNA
REMOVE 'EM TODAY.
LET'S GET THIS
ON YOU HERE.
WE'LL GET
STARTED.
WOW, DUDE.
OH, GOD!
THANK GOD.
I FELT
THAT ONE, DUDE.
ARE MY TEETH
THAT LONG?
LOOK AT
THAT TOOTH.
HOLY CRAP,
CAN I HOLD IT?
YEAH!
LOOK HOW BIG
THAT IS, JOANIE.
JOANIE GOT
FOUR TEETH PULLED OUT
AND I SAW THEM AND THEY LOOKED
LIKE DINOSAUR TEETH.
I WAS LIKE,
DAMN.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
THIS IS HAPPENING!
DANIELLE GAVE JOANIE
MORAL SUPPORT
AND A LITTLE HANDS-ON TREATMENT
FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
I WAS AT THE DENTIST OFFICE
AND GOT A LITTLE BORED.
I MEAN, WE WERE IN THERE
FOR HOURS.
JADE IS JUST
STRAPPED DOWN.
SHE GOT THIS THING
JAMMED IN HER MOUTH,
I'M LIKE, "YEAH,
YOU VULNERABLE RIGHT NOW."
I SUCTIONED HER HEAD
REAL GOOD.
SHE HAD A LITTLE PERSPIRATION
UP THERE,
SO I WANTED TO SUCK UP
THEM SWEAT BEADS.
BAM, BAM!
I HELPED
A SISTER OUT.
YOU WANT ME TO GET THAT
PERSPIRATION RIGHT THERE?
NO?
OKAY.
ARE YOU
A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL?
(record scratching)
(bell dinging)
I AIN'T
BREAK IT.
I JUST STUCK IT
TO HER FOREHEAD...
A COUPLE TIMES.
BUT JOANIE CAME AWAY
WITH THE BIGGEST SMILE OF ALL.
WE'RE ALL DONE.
LOOK WHAT
YOU GOT NOW.
OH, MY GOODNESS!
WOW,
THANK YOU!
MY PLEASURE,
MY PLEASURE.
BUT FOR BROOKE, THE SMILES
QUICKLY FADED IN JUDGING.
THIS IS SO NOT DOLL-LIKE,
REALLY, FOR ME.
THE ESSENCE OF BROOKE,
THAT'S ALL WE WANT
AND YOU HAVEN'T DELIVERED THAT
TO US IN PHOTOGRAPHS YET.
AND SHE BECAME OUR SEVENTH GIRL
ELIMINATED.
NO MORE CHANCES,
BROOKE.
I PUT SO MUCH PRESSURE
ON MYSELF TO DO SO WELL
THAT IT RESTRICTED ME,
I THINK, IN SOME WAYS.
I KNEW THAT I WAS GOING TO BE
THE ONE WHO WAS GOING HOME.
EVERY CYCLE, "AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL" GOES INTERNATIONAL
TO GIVE THE GIRLS
A MORE GLOBAL EXPERIENCE.
SO WHERE IN THE WORLD DID
"TOP MODEL" GO THIS TIME?
THAILAND!
(screaming)
THAILAND,
WHAT?
THAILAND!
THAT'S AROUND
THE WORLD.
SOME OF THE GIRLS WERE ALREADY
FEELING THE CULTURE SHOCK.
IT'S A WHOLE NEW WORLD.
LIKE WE'RE
A MAGIC CARPET.
GO OVER THERE
AND TURN IT OUT.
THAILAND.
THAILAND, BABY,
WHAT?
THAILAND.
♪♪♪
I CAN'T WAIT
TO JUST ARRIVE IN THAILAND.
IT'S JUST UNREALISTIC TO ME
RIGHT NOW.
MAN, I--
THIS IS WHY I GET NERVOUS
GOING TO AIRPORTS.
ALWAYS GOTTA
TAKE OFF YOUR--
LIKE, LOOK AT ME, I ALWAYS HAVE
TO TAKE OFF EVERYTHING,
MY BANGLES,
MY EARRINGS.
MY BOOTS-- I'M LIKE,
LOOK AT ME, MAN.
LIKE, WHAT, WHAT?
WE JUST GOT
TO THAILAND,
IT WAS A 21-HOUR FLIGHT
AND WE--
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE ALL TIRED
AND EXHAUSTED,
I'M EXTREMELY
EXCITED.
BUT THEIR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
IN THAILAND
WOULD TURN THE COMPETITION
ON ITS HEAD.
SO YOU GIRLS
ARE GONNA BE MERMAIDS
BEING PULLED OUT
OF THE WATER,
HOISTED UP IN A NET,
KIND OF ON YOUR SIDE
WITH A FISHTAIL
AND EVERYTHING.
SOME GIRLS WERE
THE CATCH OF THE DAY.
STRAIGHTEN
YOUR LEG.
AND I NEED YOU
TO BE REALLY FEMININE
ABOUT YOUR ARM
MOVEMENTS.
ANY SUGGESTIONS?
NO, I JUST--
KEEP
THE VARIETY UP.
THAT'S A PRETTY ONE,
DANIELLE,
I LIKE HOW
YOU'RE USING YOUR HANDS.
YES, OH, DO THAT, DO THAT,
DO THAT, IT'S PRETTY.
WHEN DID YOU LEARN
HOW TO BECOME SOFT?
I'M LISTENING.
I'M WATCHING
AND I'M LEARNING.
OH, OKAY.
KEEP CHANGING UP YOUR HANDS,
FURONDA.
WHILE OTHERS WERE JUST
LEFT OUT TO DRY.
THIS HARNESS
THAT THEY HAD ME IN
IS WAY, WAY TOO TIGHT IN MY
PELVIC AREA, MY WOMANLY SPACE.
THEY SAID
I LOOKED SCARED,
BUT I DIDN'T LOOK SCARED,
I LOOKED HURT.
BUT IT WAS NNENNA
WHO GOT CAUGHT IN A RUT.
NOW DON'T LET THE PAIN
SHOW IN YOUR FACE.
DON'T WORRY,
YOU'VE JUST GOT TEN FRAMES.
CAN I GET A DIFFERENT
FACIAL EXPRESSION?
I CAN'T.
I DON'T FEEL
MERMAID HERE.
YOU JUST REALLY NEED TO BRING UP
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
NOT JUST
THE SAME OLD NNENNA.
SOME OF THE JUDGES
ARE LIKE, "I'M BORED."
WHAT ELSE IS SHE BRINGING
TO THE TABLE?
AND THE JUDGES DECIDED
NNENNA'S JOURNEY WAS OVER.
I'M SURPRISED I'M THE ONE
GOING HOME TONIGHT,
BUT COMING
INTO THIS COMPETITION,
THERE ARE
NO CERTAINTIES.
NOW,
ONLY FIVE GIRLS REMAIN.
DANIELLE, THE STRIKING
GAP-TOOTHED CHARMER
FROM LITTLE ROCK,
ARKANSAS.
JOANIE,
THE SEXY PREACHER'S DAUGHTER
FROM BEAVER FALLS,
PENNSYLVANIA.
SARA, THE SIX-FOOT-ONE
GEORGETOWN GRAD
FROM DAVIS, CALIFORNIA,
WE DISCOVERED IN A MALL.
JADE, THE UNSHAKABLY CONFIDENT
AND STUNNING NEW YORKER.
AND FURONDA, THE LONG, LEAN
DIVA WITH A QUIRKY SIDE
FROM STUTTGART,
ARKANSAS.
DON'T MISS A MOMENT
AS WE FIND OUT
WHICH ONE OF THEM WILL BECOME
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
GIRL, WHY ARE YOU
GETTING UPSET?
I'M JUST--
IT'S JOKES.
TEMPERS FLARE IN THAILAND
BETWEEN JADE AND JOANIE.
YOU'RE SO DEFENSIVE,
JADE.
I AM NOT!
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO CHANGE ANYTHING.
ARE YOU TYRA,
JOANIE?
I'M JUST SAYING.
♪ LIES. ♪
LISTEN
TO YOURSELF.
AND ONE GIRL IS RUSHED
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM.